[Aplausos]
[Música]
indonesia es un país famoso por tener el
presidente más heavy del mundo y lo digo
en serio el señor cuidado es bien
conocido por ser un auténtico fanático
del heavy metal
incluso los mismísimos judas priest le
invitaron públicamente a un concierto
solo con esto ya se ha ganado varios
puntos en visual político pero hay algo
más porque no os equivoquéis por muy fan
que sea de los judas a cuidado o como se
le conoce en el país
djokovic no le gusta nada eso del
breaking the law atentos a la noticia
el presidente indonesio paga 800 dólares
por un regalo de metallica lo importante
de esta noticia no es que ha huido le
guste metallica lo realmente importante
es que haya pagado 800 dólares de su
propio bolsillo por el final
[Música]
veréis cuando eres presidente de un país
es normal que recibas en tu palacio a
grandes personalidades políticos
intelectuales y por supuesto a artistas
como puedan ser metálica o quien sea en
estos casos el protocolo dice que el
invitado tiene que hacerte un regalo
simbólico obras de arte antigüedades o
en este caso una edición rara del master
of puppets como os podéis imaginar estos
regalos pueden generar conflictos de
intereses y por eso en casi todos los
países del mundo hay leyes que prohíben
que los políticos se los queden
normalmente estos regalos se los queda
el estado en muchos casos se guardan los
seos para que la gente los pueda visitar
en el caso de indonesia a we do do le
hacía mucha ilusión tener este disco de
metallica porque es más heavy que una
lluvia de hachas y siendo el presidente
podría haberse saltado la ley sin
problemas sin embargo decidió hacerlo
legalmente y compró el disco al estado
indonesia si esto ocurriera en otro país
sería algo normal pero en indonesia los
políticos honestos son como los
marcianos nadie los ha visto nunca como
veremos más adelante
indonesia ha tenido los políticos más
corruptos de la historia y creedme no es
ninguna exageración estoy diciendo
literalmente que el líder más corrupto
de la historia fue uno de sus ex
presidentes y todo esto explica porque
el pasado mes de abril 85 millones de
indonesios le volvieran a votar para un
segundo mandato
djokovic es toda una revolución para
indonesia y no creáis que hablamos de un
país cualquiera se trata del país más
poblado de todo el mundo musulmán con
más de 255 millones de habitantes pero
sin duda alguna la mayor apuesta de
cuidado es esta noticia
bienvenidos a la jungla indonesia escoge
lugar para su nueva capital
efectivamente
indonesia ha anunciado que cambiara de
capital en 2024 noticias así no se
producen todos los días pero tampoco os
vengáis arriba que no es la primera vez
en la historia que ocurre algo así ahí
está a brasil nigeria o kazajistán que
también han cambiado de capital en las
últimas décadas sin embargo el cambio de
capital de indonesia tiene mucho que
contar los que seguís visual polític
desde hace tiempo ya recordaréis este
vídeo en el que cauto os hablaba del
despeje de indonesia entonces os
hablábamos de cómo este país aspiraba a
convertirse en la nueva superpotencia
musulmana
tras décadas de dictaduras y gobiernos
que lideran todos los rankings de
corrupción
indonesia está empezando a hacer las
cosas bien cuidado podrá gustar más o
menos si su gobierno está probando
algunas leyes bastante discutibles pero
por el momento no tiene ningún escándalo
de corrupción a sus espaldas y creedme
en un país como indonesia eso es
prácticamente un milagro lo común está
utilizando los recursos de indonesia
para de verdad solucionar los problemas
de los indonesios así que la pregunta es
por qué yo cuidado tiene que yakarta
deje de ser la capital de indonesia
tiene sentido de verdad llevarse la
capital a la jungla o es un capricho del
presidente hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
yakarta la ciudad un vida cambiar la
capital de una ciudad a otra es algo que
me toca muy personalmente por qué pues
porque si no lo sabéis
yo soy de valladolid en españa por
cierto un abrazo a todos los pucelanos
que me estáis viendo y muchos pensaréis
valladolid es
donde estaba y ha dolido pues mirad
listos resulta que valladolid fue la
capital de españa durante seis años eso
fue a principios del siglo 17 y os
preguntaréis por qué pues fue un
pelotazo urbanístico en aquel momento el
duque de lerma que era algo así como el
presidente del gobierno de aquel
entonces se dedicó a comprar terrenos y
palacios en mi ciudad
y para revalorizar los convenció al rey
de que trasladará la capital a
valladolid de la noche a la mañana
todas esas propiedades multiplicaron su
valor y que hizo el duque de lerma en
ese momento exacto venderlo todo y
convertirse en el hombre más rico de
españa en aquella época seis años
después repitió la operación en madrid y
ahí es cuando madrid pasó a convertirse
en la capital de españa hasta nuestros
días como veis hay cosas en nuestra
querida piel de toro que nunca han
cambiado pero este no es el único
ejemplo histórico y la delfín nueva york
fueron capitales de eeuu mientras se
construía de la nada washington dc que
fue una ciudad creada por y para ser la
sede del gobierno
y algo parecido ocurrió con san
petersburgo que la construyó un zar que
quería que fuera la capital de rusia
durante siglos en este caso pues la idea
no le salió como esperaba pero bueno
volvamos a indonesia en el año 1949
indonesia se independizó de los países
bajos y pronto se dieron cuenta de que
tenían un problema fijaos en el mapa
aquí podéis ver como inglés ya está
formado por más de 17.000 islas habéis
oído bien y para que os hagáis una idea
entre papúa que está aquí y hace que es
la isla más occidental hay más de 5 mil
kilómetros de distancia además tienen
más de 260 millones de habitantes en
otras palabras que es un país
prácticamente imposible de gobernar como
os podéis imaginar indonesia necesita
unas infraestructuras carísimas para
conectar sus islas y no las tiene
[Música]
conclusión que casi toda la población se
concentra en la isla de java y más
concretamente en la capital yakarta el
centro político y económico del país y
qué pasa cuando una ciudad crece sin
control y no hay dinero para construir
nuevas carreteras ni redes de
alcantarillado pues esto es lo que pasa
[Música]
yakarta desperdicia 5000 millones de
dólares cada año por los atascos
pensando bien a día de hoy hay más de 30
millones de personas viviendo en el área
metropolitana de yakarta y como el
ayuntamiento no ha construido apenas
redes de saneamiento el 30 por ciento de
las familias no tienen agua corriente de
sus casas así que qué hacen para beber
agua puedes construir pozos ilegales
esto tiene dos problemas por un lado el
agua que sale de estos pozos es más
turbia que los libros de cuentas de
odebrecht pero es que por el otro lado
genera un problema ambiental de primer
nivel habéis oído bien podríamos decir
que los ya cárteles están con el agua al
cuello
literalmente
[Música]
yakarta la ciudad que más rápido se
hunde en el mundo veréis yakarta se
erigió en un terreno pantanoso en el que
confluyen hasta 13 ríos ahora se está
hundiendo unos 15 centímetros cada año
la mitad de yakarta ya está por debajo
del nivel del mar y su población va a
seguir creciendo para que os hagáis una
idea se espera que dentro de 10 años
tenga más población que el mismísimo
tokio y cuál es la solución para evitar
este desastre pues nuestro amigo yo
cowie todo lo tiene muy claro
cambiar la capital puede parecer una
locura pero tiene bastante lógica resad
lo bien si movemos todas las
instituciones a otra ciudad también se
mudarán todos los funcionarios que
trabajan en ella y con ellos todos los
empleos indirectos el problema es que es
una mudanza de este estilo no es
precisamente barata se trata de
construir una macro ciudad desde cero y
la pregunta es tiene indonesia el dinero
suficiente para acometer semejante
inversión pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Música]
el legado de yoko wing sí es cierto
gobernar indonesia puede ser muy
complicado ahora bien hay un motivo por
el cual si jugáis a light of empires
siempre querría ser indonesia y es que
mis queridos amigos de visual político
cuando se repartieron las materias
primas este archipiélago quedó muy pero
que muy bien parado oro petróleo gas
madera papel vamos que no tienen una
perspectiva tan mala pero cuál es el
riesgo de tener tanta riqueza natural
pues que muchas veces toda esa riqueza
se queda en manos del dictador corrupto
de turno en este caso hablamos de
sukarno el padre de la patria
súccar no estuvo dos décadas en el poder
y terminó siendo uno de los hombres más
ricos del mundo y tras él llegó el
general su alto y que creéis que hizo su
arte durante unos 30 años de dictadura
pues básicamente su harto su harto a
robar de hecho también terminó
convirtiéndose en uno de los hombres más
ricos del mundo mira de esta portada de
la revista 'time' del año 1999
suharto sociedad limitada como construyó
una fortuna familiar el mandamás de
indonesia hablamos de un saqueo de más
de 15 mil millones de dólares de hecho
en 2004 transparencia internacional hizo
un ranking con los políticos más
corruptos de todos los tiempos y sus
hartos se llevó el premio vamos que a su
lado fujimori o duvalier son un político
danés y como os podéis imaginar todas
esas fortunas que iban a los bolsillos
de los políticos es dinero que no se
invertía en infraestructuras básicas así
que qué creéis que ha pasado cuando los
políticos indonesias han dejado de robar
puestos están increíbles
cómo está mirad qué derroche de
innovación llegó a indonesia en marzo de
2019 y 6-6 recalcó marzo de 2019
[Música]
el primer metro de indonesia abren
yakarta ahogada por el tráfico 30 años
ha tardado el metro en hacerse realidad
desde que se planificó y sabéis cuál ha
sido el factor decisivo para que por fin
una de las ciudades más pobladas del
mundo tenga metro pues dos palabras yo
con cuidado con yoko cuidado como
gobernador de yakarta comenzaron las
obras hace seis años y con yoko cuidado
como presidente de indonesia se han
terminado y de hecho esto es el pilar de
su gobierno e infraestructuras un mega
plan de construcción de infraestructuras
por todo el país fijado en más de 300
mil millones de dólares y cuando
hablamos de un archipiélago dominado por
la jungla os aseguro que no es ningún
capricho
[Música]
más de 3000 km de ferrocarriles y otros
tantos de carreteras puertos marítimos y
aeropuertos muchos los trayectos se han
reducido a un tercio del tiempo que
requería antes imaginar una mercancía
que antes necesitaba tres horas para
hacer un desplazamiento muy sencillo y
que ahora se tarda en menos de 60
minutos obviamente tiene un efecto
directo en la economía pero esperad un
momento porque hay algo que falta en
esta fórmula la inversión privada
como os podéis imaginar un plan tan
ambicioso como éste necesita mucho
dinero y la ayuda privada es muy
importante
[Música]
y esto explica que por mucho que cuidado
prometiera un crecimiento del 7 anual
indonesia solo ha crecido al 5% es decir
que en lo que a crecimiento se refiere
indonesia todavía sigue estando como con
los anteriores presidentes corruptos y
diréis porque no hay inversión privada
pues lo cierto es que indonesia es un
país extremadamente hermético una
empresa extranjera solamente puede
instalarse en indonesia si antes se
asocia con una compañía local
[Música]
y muchos sectores todavía permanecen en
manos de las empresas estatales por eso
actualmente la inversión extranjera
apenas supone un 15 por ciento del pib
de indonesia una cifra muy baja respecto
a otros países asiáticos pero también
tenemos que añadir el factor trabajo la
indemnización por despido en indonesia
es la tercera más alta del mundo y los
sueldos en este país son un 45% más
altos que en países vecinos como vietnam
y mientras tanto el gobierno sigue
empeñado en echar a cualquier potencia
al inversor con noticias como esta
[Música]
la mayor mina de oro del mundo es
nacionalizada en indonesia y todo esto
son malas noticias porque índoles ya va
a registrar muchísima inversión si
realmente quiere cambiar de capital
actualmente la isla de java que es donde
está yakarta concentra el 60% del pib de
indonesia y la isla de borneo donde se
construirá la nueva capital apenas el 8%
cambiar la capital de isla va a ser el
gran legado de nuestro amigo yo comido
pero también es un reto de proporciones
nat so brig alianzas el gobierno cifra
en 33 mil millones de dólares el coste
de levantar una nueva capital en la
jungla esto es el coste de dos juegos
olímpicos y todo ya ha dicho que el
estado sólo puede aportar el 20 por
ciento
[Música]
así que el otro 80% tiene que venir de
manos privadas y las manos privadas no
van a interesarse en esta inversión si
no se cambia la legislación así que
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros si os
parece este cambio de capital que
propone yoko we do do también conocido
como yo code creéis que indonesia podrá
modernizarse y también os gustaría
cambiar la capital de vuestro país
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios mientras tanto no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que es suscribiros a visual
político y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]